Hello, there.
I'm Gavin.
I'm Dan.
And a lot of people on the internet, Dan
have commented on the
state of your lab coat.
Look at it.
I mean, it's absolutely guppy, look at it.
It's rag order, blood, watermelon, paint.
We lost the sleeve very early.
Yeah, holes.
But we've stuck with it,
but I think it's time for a replacement
Yeah?
And Tide have stepped up to the plate
and given you a brand new white lab coat.
Sweet.
Put that on.
Look at this, it's almost
too bright for my eyes.
Yeah.
Does it fit, as well?
Now, enjoy the cleanliness, for a moment.
Have you enjoyed it?
Yeah.
Right, now we're going
to get it really dirty
and see if they can wash it out.
Motherfu...
All right, Dan, you got your goggles on?
Yeah, my body is ready.
Excellent, here we go.
Starting with ketchup.
This just isn't going to do, is it?
Ugh.
I'll be right back.
Fine.
Oh, yeah.
Seriously?
What is that?
Thoughts?
Uh, I'm a bit scared, actually.
Whoa, incoming.
Ah.
Oof!
Go me on the jugular with it.
Oh, you can see the recoil.
Whoa.
Jesus.
That was really direct, actually.
That is lovely.
Look at that.
Look at you.
Oh, man.
It certainly hit my throat,
literally took my jugular out there.
I've never fired
a gore goop blaster cannon before.
I would say that's
pretty solid aim on the first try.
Yeah, congrats, brother.
You hit the target.
It's just disgusting.
Oh, one of your legs...
It's really gross, yeah.
Oh, I didn't see that before.
Oh, I didn't even notice that.
Oh.
All right, Dan,
I've reloaded this thing
with some chocolate pudding.
Oh, joy.
All right, ready?
Yeah.
Gonna fire.
Ah.
Ugh, fire dammit!
Oh, God!
It cleared the goggles off.
It's in my eyelashes.
I got pudding in my eyelashes.
Shut up.
Is it delicious, though?
I mean, chocolate, yeah
but chocolate mixed with
ketchup, absolutely not.
It's disgusting.
Oh, God, it looks like...
oh, man.
You nailed it
'cause it's an upwards shot.
I can't believe it
knocked your goggles off.
It did, it's an upwards shot.
Ya knocked my goggles off
straight up my face.
Look at that spread.
Can you actually see my pupil?
'Cause I can't see down the
lens with that chocolate milk,
chocolate pudding in mine, either.
It's dripping out.
Oh, it's gross.
Oh, I can't even wipe
it off with my hands.
This might be one
of the most disturbing
things I've ever filmed.
Oh, it's slightly better.
So, chocolate pudding makes
quite good hair gel, actually.
It looks good.
Yeah.
We got to move on to some
different colors, maybe.
Maybe a bit chocolate chip ice cream.
So, this is mint chocolate chip?
Mint chocolate chip.
Oh, okay.
You just get me straight
in my face right now.
All right, three...
Oh!
I was not expecting that.
That's just mean.
Did I accidentally get
you right in the face?
Yeah, accidentally on purpose, you dink.
A little bit, yeah.
Right in the face .
You just turned a
completely different color.
Oh, man.
Oh, that is gross.
Well, I'm not being funny, Dan.
That might be the most fun
I've ever had making a slimer guys video .
I was absolutely honking.
I feel disgusting.
That's gross.
You read all these flavors to me now.
I have?
Yeah.
Don't.
It's not worth it.
Yeah?
Don't do it, stop it .
Disgusting.
Well, it's now up to Tide
to try and get this lab coat clean.
Yeah, thanks to you,
they've got, they've
got their work cut out.
They do, indeed.
You can watch that process
over on the Tide channel by
clicking the link in
the description below.
Feel free to follow us on Twitter.
Subscribe to us by shirt.
Eh, eh?
Not this one.
You definitely don't want that one.
But you know that feeling
where you get something
sticky on your hands,
it's kind of sticky.
Really annoying.
Especially when you like hold a fork.
Yeah, really annoying.
You're like, "Oh, that's gross."
Yeah, I've got that all over my body.
That is unfortunate.
Look, before...
I thought you were going
to splat me with it.
...After.
Well, I can give you a hug, if you want.